this time we're trying to make you
forget
who you are
and where you came from
i kind of have to start with you and
getting this role because everybody has
big shoes to fill but the shoes you had
to fill were involved in the process of
making this one so
talk about your conversations with will
i heard his audition was informal what
was yours like uh
very formal i i did the uh
sent in a self tape uh didn't hear
anything for a couple of weeks uh then i
got the call back on my birthday right
and immediately then i knew
you know i know nothing happens for no
reason right and and uh i knew that
there was some sort of spiritual
element working around
this show and you know i definitely
wanted to
you know give it my all i had to you
know when i got when i saw i got the um
call for it i was like i know this is me
and and i believe if you ask for
something the universe or god will send
it your way it just depends on who you
are when it comes you know what i mean
and and so i i was i felt like i was
ready and you know i did the whole
process and got down to the final
producer call
and uh
and i was like i made it this far let's
do it and i finished finish it up i felt
pretty good about it my uh my manager
calls me he says um
you should hear something in three to
four days
was okay three four days boom then sleep
at all right three to four days go by
nothing
and i'm like oh my god i didn't get it i
didn't get it i got this far i didn't
get it uh and uh the fifth day rolls by
and morgan cooper uh his
uh assistant bernardo he calls me he
says morgan wants to do one more
creative special with you and i'm like
oh my god i'm like oh my god oh my god i
got all my stuff ready i'm like i don't
know what he wants to see but i'm gonna
show him everything i absolutely have in
this moment on this call and i had all
my sides ready i was ready to go ready
to rock i click the zoom link log on
and
there's will smith
and i'm like
wow i'm just stunned and and i thought
that it was a pre-recorded video because
his camera was so clear
and but he goes uh yo what's up philly
what's up philly i'm like oh hey
and uh
and he's like i want to congratulate you
you got the part of will on belair and
uh man i was stuck i was stuck i'm
stunned and i'm so grateful in that
moment and that is a moment that i'll
never ever forget you know it's it's uh
it's so beautiful because the world
really saw my life got flipped turned
upside down you know in front of their
faces and uh and that reaction was so
priceless yeah and we get to watch all
the incredible and iconic beats from the
series come back again that was such a
great thing about morgan's vision was
sort of updating the show from a sitcom
to like a real drama so i just have to
ask you i mean obviously you were a fan
if you're like first call like let me do
this
what
now knowing you're gonna step into this
character through several different
iconic moments which one are you looking
forward to just seeing what morgan and
the writing team can do or like what
you'll be able to do is there a moment
from the series that you're like when we
get there i can't wait i i'd be really
interested in seeing
uh
will and uh jackie's relationship jackie
who was played by tyra banks and uh you
know just having that philly come come
to bel air again and seeing their
dynamic and you know will has changed a
little bit and so you know
uh you know because i think you know
there's when will first gets to bel air
he he looks at carlton is like oh like
you know you're out of touch bro like
you know what i mean and and so
uh jackie and will having that dynamic
as well and jackie going yo well you're
out of touchdown you all belair now yeah
that's gonna be super exciting first
i'm not gonna be sad about that she's uh
she's got my real name i mean it's
jacqueline right
yeah exactly does this mean you get to
just text will all the time now
um
i'm gonna keep that a secret
that's right he's got his phone number
find and find him right about
hold him how you been
you know
thriving
[Applause]
i hope uh one day we can talk about why
you're really here first i have to start
like i feel embarrassed to say this i
don't even want to ask i know what
you're going to say i don't want to ask
but i know you guys are established
actors and i know you do your homework
so i know you watch the original series
and i know you're like fans what's a
moment that you were excited to see re
done again in this new imagining and
ollie i'll start with you
oh see that was a good question because
you're trying to get spoilers i see what
you're doing you're trying to get
spoilers um what i will say is that the
show
our version of the show touches on a lot
of those classic moments unfortunately
i'm just not going to tell you specifics
right now
um because i want you to watch the show
streaming on peacock uh february 13th
um maybe one thing i can say is that
you'll get to see the love that you
were so drawn to in the fresh prince of
bel-air this is all of the family yes
this family here we really do love each
other we have really grown close during
this whole journey and that is very
apparent in our chemistry on screen
yeah
i'm tired of y'all i'm tired of seeing
y'all so much but i'm not thanks i keep
coming back you know you'll be like
tonight
what are you guys doing later
one of the great things that cassandra
told me is how the freedom that morgan
gave you all with your characters to
really make them your own and not be
concerned with the legacy of the
original show but i was just wondering
in your conversations with him what
maybe did he say were aspects of those
characters he wanted the audience to
fall in love with this time around and
akira i'll start with you well what
morgan told me he said that
ashley is
i think he kind of said that she was
like the glue that keeps the family
together and
she's super smart so she's super white
so she's really wise beyond her years
and
i think that's kind of what i portray
for people like
just show how how smart she is how
much wisdom she has like and what how
well she is um like just about knowing
the world how informed she is as a jen's
ear and how they're like more in
depth yeah she really reflects
off of her generation and wants to
show a change
i think the most beautiful thing about
magic is you can't ever really plan it
so you know i will say i've never i
never had a conversation with morgan
where he was like okay so this thing
about carlton the original i kind of
want you to there was never that it was
just so
it's so yeah it's so inherent in the
writing
that uh morgan rasheed and tj have given
us and in the story that it's hard for
that not to just show up and like i said
but like cassandra was saying with the
freedom that he gives us he's like go
play go shine and you know i think the
magic just sort of happens coco
i mean i'll put it to you this way
she was loved but let's just say like in
the original series we had our moments
we will read
what are you doing but this this version
of of her is is different in so many
ways and i'm just curious like what were
you excited about in your character sort
of bringing to the forefront that i that
you felt was maybe new well first of all
definitely the representation of
dark-skinned
powerful boss woman also i was really
excited to
portray a different way to be sexy and
classy and all these looks like i hope
they inspire
you know just a different way to express
yourself creatively like and i think
hillary also speaks on like being overly
sexualized or being like watered down in
order to like
feel like you fit somewhere and i love
that she's so boldly transparent about
the ways that the world can try to press
you down like i think her story relates
to me of course being in this industry
since i was a kid but i hope that it
will relate to a lot of other women who
look like me
that is so true i mean i'm going to ask
everyone this but i believe the answer
so have none of y'all met your
counterparts or spoken to the previous
virgin's counterparts at all or do you
want to i'll put it that way and here
i'll start with you
well i actually have talked to tatiana
ali
she was so
nice when i talked to her and she was
just telling me
everything like she told me about how
she felt when she found out there was a
reboot she just told me a bunch of stuff
and
the one thing that i always remember is
that she um she told me i had the role
of ashley now i'm passing it down to you
so i was that was really i would have
cried
oh
[Music]
and i did get to speak to karen as well
um that conversation was also iconic she
was telling me that she's completely
opposite from hillary and um she really
loved that even when we got to talk she
was like i can tell you're exactly like
her you're like charming you're dynamic
you're a go-getter you're really like
relatable and down to earth and
that's something that i'm glad that
hillary is like really giving out
um but it was great for her to really
give me that like you're doing good
approval i love that for everyone here
and carl like carl y'all you and alfons
are gonna have to just get together
right yeah no fox and i don't get
together you know he's he's a little
busy at the moment but we
we've scheduled something you know i was
texting him yeah yeah i was texting him
the other day i was like hey yo it's
like what's up we're going to publish
excellent excellent maybe will just
doesn't cut out for this why are we
working so hard to save a boy who
doesn't want to be safe
because we owe it to him
first and foremost um with a show like
this i know y'all were there i know you
had to have been watching it when it
came out and so what moments when you
found out that you're going to be part
of this reimagining where you're just
like i have to see this redone i'm so
excited to portray it on
screen when i saw the trailer the
original trailer i thought i i'm so
excited to see this redone but i didn't
think that i was going to be a part of
this process no who does that i was
never in my wildest in my way
they saw this happening for them they
might be a bit narcissistic yeah 100
yeah so the fact that we're here we're
just like it's it's such a surreal
moment uh to to be uh you know
on this journey um we're just yeah we're
super humbled and you know i feel like
the fresh prince might as well be like a
holiday it's something that all of us so
love it's you know it's a gift and so we
feel like it's a gift as much to sit in
the seat as it is to give it away at the
same time but it's a shared love from a
whole community it's so nostalgic for us
as well as it is for you know everyone
so just being here on set playing these
roles it's like yeah yeah when he calls
me vivian banks on set i'm still just
like moment right like why
yesterday we shot someone i was like
something something phillip banks and i
was like what am i doing
i do i do love it though and i love you
like what are you talking about i don't
know i love like y'all and everything
it's like it's just the way that y'all
vibe and i'm just curious
who when you guys sort of met if any of
you i first i should ask did any of you
meet your counterpart prior to coming
into this role or did you get to chat
with them yeah we well i mean we knew
each other for the past like 10 years or
so uh
no i meant your original characters
sorry but both of you are oh like the
original oh yeah
oh never mind oh oh like
yeah
oh no like it's different jeff i think
jimmy's the only thing he did jimmy
worked with uh yeah the original
carefree yeah he played his son actually
um morgan is such a huge part of this
and i'm just curious especially with
your two characters he really shifted
how they act in this series without
question they have
very much changed with the times and
they're just completely dif they're
different characters but they're the
same as when they were before um i'll
start with you cassandra what vision did
he sort of have for your character that
he wanted to make sure
you know he brought over from the
original and what specifically new did
you want to bring to her
i mean
morgan was so generous to say to us that
we had no obligation to fill the shoes
that were already made he's like listen
those were done he's like this is a
chance for you to create your own shoes
um but there is a vibe and he's a very
musical person he has such a great ear
for truth and authenticity so he sent me
a whole playlist of music that felt like
the vibe of vivian and i was such a
solid playlist yeah he sent it to
everyone and so give me a banger i got
it oh oh listen listen if you heard this
music it's a lot of great 90s music when
he sent it to me i thought maybe i am
viviane banks because these are all my
favorites everything a lot of the songs
i already listened to were on my
playlist so it was just the main thing i
wanted to do is like have the the the i
just want to make sure she was grounded
in being like
real as in like this is a woman from
philadelphia it's not someone as if
she's speaking from juilliard which
happens sometimes for some of us um
i i wanted her to feel like no she's
comfortable in her own skin with this
wealth and let's talk about something
else yeah she very much embodied that
she used to be there from around the way
i love that i love that oh yeah that's
that's a big thing from morgan he was
like no we need to know that that's not
gone from her and i was like great
because i'm not interested in playing
someone who wants to erase her so no
absolutely not but she has a race parts
of herself don't get into it
okay uh but i feel like it's the erasure
that many women do of color to try to
fit in and so the way she looks
these first few episodes is very
specific a woman trying to fit into a
world
of motherhood and being the wife of a
candidate all that kind of stuff i
really just want to really quickly talk
about the political aspect of phil in
this one because it is very different if
you could just give me a little bit on
what was interesting about approaching
that yeah well you know he uh he's
really um
he's a very just very fair man and and
so
the the the crooked justice system
that we are all uh have all been exposed
to is something that's uh on his uh
on his you know it's very important for
him to to to fix you know and so he's
he's that that's that's his campaign he
wants to get into he wants to become the
d.a so that he can um
make the crooked road straight and and
for for for young black men because so
many of us are falsely accused and and
um you know doing time
for overcharging overture yeah over time
for little petty crimes you know
so he's just he just wants to um
do right and and and make it right for
for everyone and so
yeah that's that's his uh
his mo do you know why i'm here from
philly scrapping the ball court
[Music]
got nasty
now some bad man from philly he wanted
to deal with you
well first let me say congratulations on
the series as somebody that watched the
entire series all the way through i'm
just curious what moments were you guys
excited to recreate when you found out
you're going to be a part of this new
reimagining and jimmy i'll start with
you
oh really a really good question in
terms of a moment that's not connected
to jeffrey for me it was a sort of will
turning up to school and and seeing how
that would go down and so when you see
the trailer the way they captured that
moment that i think if i'm right that
wasn't scripted i think that was just
jabari being in the flow and being the
amazing superstar that he already is um
so i love seeing that uh explored and i
think in terms of jeffrey i i'm looking
forward to
exploring
the elements of to find out about his
backstory we're gonna we've got two
years two seasons to explore that but
also there's that moment in the original
when him and phil go out um and he says
bring out is it the seal right maybe the
pool scene the course
but i really enjoy phil and jeffrey
being equals you know and there's no dis
in his love his brothery brotherly love
and camaraderie and uh and black
excellence there is nothing about
jeffrey in this one that feels a part of
service more than just real
companionship and that's really a
testament to both you as actors uh
bringing it on to the rest of you so uh
jordan i'll start with you what what did
you want to bring back and recreate with
your character or any of them
uh one thing obviously that everybody
loved about jazz he had
a great sense of style we have that here
i i don't want to you know compete but i
might have even be a little bit more
dripped you know in this one you know uh
so that that's been great just my
wardrobe and all of that just you know
when you have the kind of correct
wardrobe as well you can be more
comfortable and and not so in your head
about certain things but in all honesty
what i was excited to see
uh was the basketball scene at the
beginning because you know in the in the
original song it's it's comedic like the
one little fighter my mom got and and
then like like you said jimmy we just
show up at the door you know what i'm
saying we really just show up
like right from will's perspective where
we get a chance to see
all the philly stuff and how that fight
actually would have went down if it was
now and dramatic with police brutality
which is definitely uh you know current
and still as all has always been but um
just seeing how that situation played
out and how he actually got to l.a
and i'm also really glad about how it
turned out yes yeah turned out
incredible i mean people are already
talking about it i've seen it and i
can't wait for them simone says i i have
to ask you man like there's so many
moments say your character in the
original series had that i would want to
recreate i think every young black girl
did
right i always say like when i first got
this i was just like this is a dream
that i did not know that could come true
you know when you're watching it as a
girl you're like oh man like i wish i
could do that and i was like wait a
minute what um so
um
you know what
the best parts
that i loved were the way she like
the way lisa was a guide for him in a
way you know they were always joking but
she was really a game changer for him
because you know he's over here chasing
running and then he could really stood
still when she told him to and so in
this
[Music]
but you know we kind of start there we
start from a place of strength but not
control and love but not like uh like
not a desperation and so i think in that
way we get to we get to explore new
sides of both of their characters yeah
i've got every girl want to be lisa
listen we did a like epk shoot like
probably the first day we all met you
know and uh after table read and
watching jabari and simone just connect
we looked around the monitor like this
that we're on with you and there was
about 30 people you know just left it
because the chemistry the beauty just
you're not seeing without the poor parts
you just really believed it immediately
and you can't make that up you can't buy
that and around and probably it was like
20 guys i mean the women was like get
out of the way
it's just such a beautiful moment and i
just think you guys have captured that
beautifully and that's going to you know
keep viewers interested in classes
real quick and y'all talk to your
characters just give me a quick hey if
you've talked to your original character
yes i spoke to joseph yes
you